What I want to do in this video
is talk a little bit
about traditional IRAs.
IRA stands for Individual
Retirement Account.
Individual
Retirement
Account.
The focus on this video
is the traditional IRA.
You'll hear of other types of IRAs,
especially Roth IRA and SEP IRAs.
This is only on Traditional.
The just of all of them,
is really it's the governments way
of encouraging you to
save for your retirement.
They all have slightly different details,
so I'm just going to focus
on the traditional right now.
Let's say we are in year 0.
That's right now.
Instead of year 0, let
me write "right now."
You have 2 options.
You could take advantage
of the traditional IRA.
This is the IRA scenario.
This is the no IRA scenario.
Now, an IRA allows you
to put up to a certain
amount of your income aside.
Depending on your age and what year it is,
that amount will change.
In 2010 that number is $5,000
if you are under the age of 50.
For under 50.
It's $6,000 ...
This is for an individual,
not for a family.
It's $6,000 if you're over the age of 50.
Over age of 50.
I guess the rational was probably,
"Gee, if you're over the age of 50,"
"you better save even
more for your retirement,"
"which might only be 10 or 15 years away."
They gave a little bit more
lead way for over the age of 50.
Let's say we're under the age of 50
and we take full advantage of this IRA.
We set aside $5,000.
$5,000.
Here we set aside nothing.
Set aside nothing.
In the very short term,
the advantage is that
this $5,000 of our income
will not be taxed.
Let's say that my tax bracket ...
Let's say that I'm in a 32% tax bracket.
32% tax bracket.
Let me write that on the side.
It will apply to both scenarios.
32% tax bracket today.
I'm making some good money.
Tax bracket today.
On the $5,000 only,
I'm only talking about
the taxes on the $5,000.
You're going to have to pay taxes above
and beyond that on the
rest of your income.
Today, I'm going to pay
0 taxes on that $5,000.
0 taxes on the $5,000.
If I don't set aside
that $5,000 into an IRA,
then I will have to pay
taxes on that $5,000.
I'm going to have to pay $5,000 x 32%.
Which is equal to what?
I'll just get a calculator out.
You get 5,000 x .32 = $1,600 in taxes,
I'm going to pay $1,600 in taxes today.
In the year that I
actually made that $5,000.
I can't set aside $5,000
if I made less than $5,000.
It's always the lower of your income
or these IRA limits.
Of course, you're going to
pay, even in this situation.
Let's say you made $100,000.
When you put the $5,000 aside,
you're still going to have
to pay taxes on $95,000.
In this situation, where you
didn't put the $5,000 aside,
you're going to have to
pay taxes on $100,000.
You're going to have to pay
taxes on the extra $5,000,
which is $1,600.
Let's say in either
situation, with that $5,000,
you want to buy and sell some securities
or some investments.
Let's say right after you
put in the IRA account …
Now everything is sitting
in our IRA account.
All of our transactions are sitting
in this special IRA account right here,
where we can actually
buy and sell investments
and trade them.
But, we can't cash them in
and turn them into cash
and then spend it on a new
car or something like that.
If we did do that,
before the age of 59 1/2, we
would have to pay a penalty.
Let me write that down.
You might immediately say,
"Hey gee, this is a good idea."
"Why doesn't everyone always do it?"
The answer is, if I pull
it out before 59 1/2,
I pay a penalty.
Let me write this down,
because that's important to keep in mind.
Pay penalty and taxes if
withdrawn before 59 1/2.
Once again, this is the Traditional IRA.
The Roth IRA, for example,
is a little bit more flexible on the
actual principle amount that
you put into the account.
We're just dealing with Traditional.
This is an important
thing to keep in mind.
This is kind of the
tradeoff that you're giving.
The government is saying,
"Hey, I'm giving you an
incentive to put this aside"
"and I really want to make
sure that you leave this aside"
"until you are ready to retire."
"You don't get tempted, when
you see a nice sports car,"
"to cash in your IRA and use it,"
"because you're going to
have to pay a penalty."
As long as you don't actually withdraw it
and turn it into cash,
you can actually buy and sell
securities within that IRA.
Let's say, as soon as you put that $5,000,
you buy $5,000 of stock A.
Here, we don't have $5,000 anymore.
We only have $3,400 of
our original amount,
so we buy $3,400 of stock A.
Let's say, I don't know,
10 years in the future.
Let's say in 10 years ...
This is going to be in either situation.
In 10 years, let's say
that stock A has doubled,
and you sell it.
Now, you sell it.
You have $10,000 here.
You have $10,000 from sale of A.
It's doubled.
Here's it's doubled,
but you only have $3,400 of stock A.
Now, that $3,400 is worth $6,800.
You have $6,800 from sale of A.
Let's say you want to put
that into another stock.
Let's say you put that all into stock B.
I'm painting a very rosy picture.
You can't always insure
that stocks will double.
You buy $10,0000 in this situation.
$10,000 of B.
I'll hold off there.
You buy $10,000 of B.
Here you might say,
"Oh, I'm going to buy $6,800 of B.
Because you are not operating
within an IRA account,
you're going to have to pay
taxes on the capital gains
from this right here.
Capital gains are gains made
from capital investments.
In this case the capital
investment is investing in stocks.
Since you owned your stock
for more that 1 year,
you at least will only have to
pay long-term capital gains,
which tends to be lower than
short-term capital gains.
In this situation you
made a $3,400 profit.
Not $340,000.
You made $3,400 profit.
You are going to have to
pay 15% capital gains.
x 15%.
Let's get the calculator out again.
3,400 x .15 = $510.
You're going to have to pay $510.
This is $510.
You take your $6,800,
pay $510 to the IRS.
You are going to be left with $6,290.
Remember, the reason why
you have to pay taxes is
this is not operating inside of an IRA.
Here you are operating inside of an IRA,
so you don't have to pay taxes.
Let's say you invest in stock B
and then over the next 10 years,
stock B also doubles.
Stock ... so this is 10 years.
Stock B is now worth
$20,000 and you sell it.
From sell of B.
Once again, it's sitting
inside of your IRA,
so you don't have to pay
any capital gains on it.
In this situation, you use that $6,290
to also invest in stock B,
and after 10 years stock B doubles.
It is now …
What is that?
$12,580.
Once again, it's sitting
outside of your IRA.
You have to pay 15% capital gains.
You had a $6,290 gain.
$6,290 gain x 15%.
Let's see what that is.
I'll get the calculator.
Where's my calculator?
There is it.
You have $6,290 x 15%.
That's equal to 943.
Let me take that from my 12,580.
12,580 - 943.5 is equal to ...
I have $11,636.
I now have $11,636.
Let's say 20 years have past.
We are now over the age of 59 1/2.
We can now withdraw from our IRA.
Of course, this situation,
this is cash that we have.
We can do anything with it.
Maybe we're now over 60 years old.
This could be used for our retirement,
for our everyday expenses.
This money that was sitting in IRA,
now that we're over the age of 60,
we're over 60 now, or over 59 1/2
if you want to be particular.
Now that we're over 60
we can withdraw the IRA
without paying any penalty,
but we will have to pay taxes.
We're going to withdraw.
No penalties.
We will have to pay taxes,
but the huge advantage here is,
once we're over 60, we're
probably earning less money.
The actual tax bracket that we're in
is probably going to be lower.
Let's say we're in a 25% tax bracket.
Remember, when we first made that $5,000
we were in a 32% tax bracket,
because we were this young gun
at the peak of his or her career,
making a lot of money.
Now, we're making less money.
We're trying to live off of our savings,
so we have to pay 25% income tax on it.
If we pay 25% on $20,000 ...
Remember, now we're
actually withdrawing it.
We're actually putting it
in our checking account
so we can spend it for living
or whatever we want to do with it.
25% of $20,00 is equal to $5,000 in taxes.
We will be left with $15,000
to do anything that we want with it.
Compare this.
This is $15,000 verses $11,636.
Everything that we did
was completely identical,
except for, over here we took the $5,000
and invested within an IRA.
Here, we took the $5,000,
we had to pay taxes on it.
Then, we invested it
in the exact same way.
We actually made very
good stock investments
in both situations
and we ended up with a
significant less amount of money.
This is $15,000 verses $11,000.
That's almost … What is that?
30 something % difference
in the total amount of money you have.
Not only that,
but this tax we had to pay,
we don't have to pay this …
this is only in situations
where you have a 25% tax rate.
When you're retired you might even
have a lower tax rate than that
and it's deferred a good bit.
The real thing to think about is just,
20 years in the future
you're sitting on $15,000
verses if you didn't
participate it in the IRA
you're sitting on only
a little over $11,500.
Of course, the main trade off here is
that in the IRA situation,
you really couldn't touch your money.
If you had an emergency
and you had to withdraw the money,
you would have had to pay penalties on it.